eux devront bel et bien prendre leur
voiture direction loches pour piquer une
tête à 30 km de chez eux cet été les
habitants de Descartes et Sainte-Maure
ne pourront pas profiter des piscines
municipales elle resteront fermées et
même définitivement pour celles de
Sainte-Maure trop cher à remplir et à
chauffer Clémence dosc
la piscine de Descartes restera fermée
cet été la faute a un bassin fissuré et
sujet à des fuites de l'eau qu'il faut
remplacer et réchauffer un manque à
gagner en période de hausse du coût des
énergies pour les communes sans compter
son déficit de 170.000 euros annuels
notion de l'acteur d'action sociale déjà
le manque de bassin pour apprendre à
nager qui est un notion importante à
prendre en compte et puis toute
l'animation estivale mais il y a aussi
une mission auprès des personnes un peu
plus âgées parce que je sais que
derrière il y a de la Chine aquatique
qui fait aussi le troisième âge trouve
un attrait assez à cet équipement les
bassins devraient ainsi être vidés et
rénovés afin de rouvrir en 2024 un coup
de jeune que ne connaîtra pas la piscine
de Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine datant des
années 60 sa fréquentation est en berne
et l'infrastructure trop vétuste la
commune préfère en construire une
nouvelle plus aux normes nous allons
construire un centre aquatique une
piscine aux normes aujourd'hui
respectant l'environnement les économies
d'énergie j'allais dire aussi
l'environnement puisque aujourd'hui tout
fait partie de de ça aujourd'hui il faut
faire des et trouver des discours des
économies tout en faisant fonctionner et
apportant une agrabilité et une j'allais
dire comment dire une attractivité à
notre territoire estimez à 5 millions
d'euros le projet devrait voir le jour
en 2026 en attendant les saintes-moriens
devront faire quelques kilomètres pour
pouvoir piquer une tête